annegret kann einfach nicht genug von
ihrer leibspeise kriegen mettbrötchen
ohne brötchen mit prüft sich viele
berichte von allen guten geistern
verlassen herz bekommt aber wieder meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren einen
applaus für euch das es geschafft hat
heute wieder einzuschalten
stabile leistung heutigen tage bis zum
ersten auf diesem kanal auf eine
wunderbare person gestoßen die die in
dem video gerade auf partnersuche war
die rede selbstverständlich von annegret
der sexbombe und zuge dessen gefühle ich
mir ein video zu beschicken mit der
bitte dass ich darauf reagiere die rede
ist von in dem einzigartigen wunderbaren
traumhaften video ein kilo matt zum
frühstück einen blog nimmt ab mit
annegret bevor wir anfangen mit einem
neuen video über unsere zauberhafte
prinzessin ganz kurzes schau dort an
meinen lieblings kommentar unter dem
letzten video da hat dummheit gebt
gesagt mein tag wurde gerade offiziell
gerettet und ich muss ganz kurz mal riet
rock mit euch reden leute für mich hat
sich überdies mit dass geist zu sehen
dass leute spaß daran haben was ich
gerade so im internet mache aber nicht
wieder fahre dass ich mit dem unsinn den
ich mitmache ein zwei leuten den tag
verschönern konnte dementsprechend an
dummheit lebt und jetzt filme einen blog
in wesseling amanda kalt und er ist
schon eine geile anfangen leute warte
ich noch mal kurz mag sein magst gibt er
ganz kurz mal die ersten sekunden von
diesem video einen blog in wesseling
amanda kalt wäre
ich frage mich schon warum ich gerade
mache bei diesen ersten drei sekunden
das lustige daran ist das ein guter
kumpel von max und mia der auch schon
mal ein video von mir war ja ja die
realität
es ist nicht so einfach aus wesseling
kommt außerdem vesterling was hier
gemeint ist es sowieso ein kleines dorf
in der nähe von köln und erzählt immer
so übelsten stories und tut so als wäre
besser liegen so dass hardcore ghetto
wenn man immer voll ausgelacht aber
jetzt wo ich das sehe er hat recht dass
alle lustigste ist dieser kumpel jan hat
heute geburtstag also lasst uns mal eine
kleine aktion unter dem video starten
und kommentierten wir alle mit wesseling
nimmt ab alles gute zum geburtstag einen
blog in wesseling amanda k s hier mitten
im rheinland leben sieben
schwergewichtige tür an tür
annegret in dem fucking gebäude alter
ihr wisst bescheid westling ist im haus
alle geräte aus das haus ist voll fast
keiner mehr rein
für den kommentar komme ich in die hölle
ich muss jetzt auch bei was ich sage
leute weil alle gerät ist dadurch so
zehn kilometer luftlinie von mir
entfernt und alle wollen nur eines weg
mit dem speck die erste im bunde ist
annegret die frührentnerin ist mit 55
jahren die älteste im block dieser die
stabilsten blog also jemand ganz ehrlich
machen uns nichts vor annegret ist die
stabilste person ingesamt wesseling
vermutlich in ganz nordrhein-westfalen
sie bringt stolze 127 kilogramm auf die
waage okay okay okay okay was passiert
hier
das sieht nicht gut aus also zu 80
prozent besteht mein leben aus es geil
ist und schmeckt und es lecker ist ein
statement ist ein statement man muss
auch dazu auch sagen es gibt auch
unterschiede zwischen ich mag essen und
ich es mir einfach rohes fleisch mit pur
ohne dass nicht mehr brötchen runter ok
für alle die sich gerade fertig ist kann
ich nicht gesehen haben heute da ist
kein brötchen und runter es ist einfach
nur so ein hut bulette mit zwiebeln
drauf und dann was das maggi das schon
hardcore all das kommt von jemandem der
wirklich perverse sachen ist okay ich
jetzt wirklich perverse sachen aber das
ist next level nicht einmal halb so alt
wie annegret dafür
30 kilo schwerer ist gesa die 24-jährige
wiegt rund 157 kilogramm und ist mehr
als unzufrieden also ich versuche ihn
vor allem eine sache zu gehen leuten
aber gc hat in den letzten videos
angeschaut haben annegret schon den
einen oder anderen spruch gedrückt dass
das geht so nicht wer sich im
wesselinger block mit allen geräten
liegt der der muss halt mit den
konsequenzen leben nicht runter sondern
hoch geht es mit single mann sascha und
seinen kilos aktuelles gewicht des
32-jährigen 144 damit gar kann einfach
keinem snack widerstehen
jetzt ist er die wurst okay okay leute
ihr seht ihr das wird das wird keine
leichte aufgabe heute hausarbeit muss
sein und zwischendurch warten macht mir
spaß und ich würde liebend gerne jetzt
zugang zu den ganzen sachen hier
interview und alter die essen alle
einfach nur med
das ist so ein sonett kracher oder so
also mettwürstchen alle geräte ist
natürlich okay sie ist auch chef im
block ne müssen wir dazu sagen muss es
vorangeht sonderrechte
ich hätte aber red bull hätte auf die
hand gepackt
ok damit ist jetzt schluss denn ab
sofort ist es ein blog nimmt ab und
damit das auch klappt steht der block ab
sofort unter dem kommando von fernanda
brandao
nein der block steht nicht unter dem
kommando von fernanda brandao
ihr könnt natürlich jemanden da rein
schicken ihr könnt eine fitnesstrainerin
die sie da rein schicken und den leuten
aber helfen damit dass sie abnehmen aber
der block ok untersteht dem kommando von
genau einer person
der ahnt schon was in sachen sport und
gesunde ernährung macht ihr keiner was
vor
bei family stories hat man sich überlegt
okay wir müssen irgendwie den leuten
beweisen dass diese fitnesstrainerin
wirklich weiß was sie macht okay ich
habe
wir hoffen sie auf eine bank springen an
der seite von fernanda wird sich dr
thomas kurscheid um die medizinische
versorgung der block bewohner kümmern
alter der gabi professionell wird ist
auf einmal geben sogar ein arzt dafür
geholt was was soll das werden rtl2
qualitätsfernsehen möchte von allen
guten geistern verlassen ich sage das
nur so dreist weil rtl 2 ab oder dem
video selbst ein kommentar rausgehauen
hat mit dem sie die leute auffordern
wollen quasi englische untertitel für
das video zu machen und sie schreiben
darin du hast nicht deutschsprachige
freunde mit denen du deine leidenschaft
wird das deutsche qualitätsprogramm
teilen möchtest was letzten endes heißen
sie nehmen sich selbst auf die schippe
und direkt darunter damit den
kommentaren wie bin ich hier gelandet
button exakt seit ein blog und wichtig
ist dass da viel teamgeist hinter steckt
dass ihr euch austausch und das ihr die
reise gemeinsam angeht wer am wenigsten
von seinem wie sage ich dass leute bevor
ich dazu sagen muss ich vorneweg
schicken das ist wirklich alles so
spaßig gehe auch niemanden auf der
persönlichen ebene an ich finde es
einfach nur so geil was für eine
botschaft an die tiere und vermittelt so
das programm hat gerade angefangen und
dies schon so
kein bock mehr ich setze mich erst mal
wer am wenigsten von seinem jetzigen
gewicht ab nimmt bekommt eine strafe
also ist es dann so cluse kennt ihr das
noch also ich habe bisher nur sehr
entfernt in der villa mit 1 2 auch so
eine sendung wo es nur darum gehen das
sollte abnehmen und wer in die am
wenigsten abgenommen hat das verloren
und wird irgendwie bestraft also ist das
quasi bewegen looser wesseling edition
ich habe angst die haben ja meine frauen
strafe kriegt oder nicht ist eigentlich
egal ich weiß nur dass ich sind kriege
auf jeden fall auch ihrem mann stabil
alles was mit meiner frau passiert wie
sie sollten mich dass der iucn bisschen
übertrieben leute wie merke schon es ist
kein spaß okay im wesselinger blog ist
bei dieser abnehmen challenge jeder auf
sich allein gestellt ich frage mich was
die blogs chefin dazu sagt ich habe
keine angst vor der strafe und ich will
es ja auch schaffen sagt ansage als
stabil die frau ist einfach stabil und
es sei jetzt nicht mehr bewohnen sinne
ohne witz ich fange wirklich so langsam
an annegret in mein herz zu schließen
ist kein scheiß ich glaube wirklich kein
scheiß aber das müsst ihr mir glauben
alle gerät ist halt einfach es hat
einfach alle gerät neben schwarz und vor
allem eine radikale ernährungsumstellung
zum ziel führen glock bewohner hat sich
für eine bestimmte diät form entschieden
ok moment ich muss kurz in frage
gestellt bevor es in der folge einfach
so gesagt wird und mich dann um haut
möglicherweise meine geistigen
gesundheit verliere die folge heißt ein
kilometer zum frühstück sobald ich das
jetzt verstanden habe ist sie bisher
noch kein kilo mehr zum frühstück heißt
es dann ihre diät besteht daraus ein
kilo mit zum frühstück zu essen ist dass
die idee ist also ich habe in der
zeitung gelesen diese heilfasten und
schonkost und die möchte ich mal gerne
ausprobieren
damit hat sich annegret mit abstand die
härteste diät ausgesucht okay okay durch
leute blog chefin annegret hat
tatsächlich bisher scheinbar ein
kilometer frisch gegessen und in ihrer
neuen diät wird sie es nicht mehr machen
gut jetzt haben sie gesagt was ihre diät
die schwerste sei von allen aber ganz
ehrlich wenn eine person dieser runde
die stabilität bis zu was zu ziehen dann
ist es eine gerät ganz einfach ich will
sind immer wieder sagen okay akzeptiert
einfach alle geräte chef bis jetzt laut
annegret gemeinsam mit ihrem sohn hubert
am liebsten richtig zu zum frühstück
gibt es brötchen dazu riesen berge mit
fleisch
okay aber ich auch ich auch leute ich es
auch sehr gern deftiges frühstück spürte
die liebe leute da ist eine verbindung
da okay alle geräte kommen uns näher
nicht auf dieser ebene auf einer
spirituellen eben besonders nach meine
zucker spritze brauche ich dann ein
deftiges frühstück annegret kann einfach
nicht genug von ihrer leibspeise kriegen
okay okay und ich bin auch weiterhin
beruhigt das scheinbar doch brötchen
unter das bett kommen mettbrötchen ohne
brötchen okay doch nicht mit prüft sich
für eine pontonbrücke alter das ist ein
fucking geiles rezept müsst ihr euch mal
gehen dann muss erstmal drauf kommen mit
brüchen ohne brötchen hat man sich schon
mal die kohlenhydrate aus dem brötchen
gespart was zählt ist einzig und allein
der geschmack
annegret macht nicht so was ich habe
mich wirklich klaus gefühl zu dir und
dann sowas maji maji maji in karachi in
karachi
nowitzki glänzte aber wir müssen uns
alle einmal kurz schütteln einfach mal
raus damit heraus mit denen aber
deutlich wir können daraus etwas
positives ziehen selbst will wesselinger
blog chefs ist es nicht leicht
abzunehmen also müssen wir uns
eigentlich auch keine vorwürfe machen
wisst ihr was leute das hat mein tag
jetzt verschönert ich kann jetzt daran
gehen das video zu schneiden und ich
fühle mich einfach ich fühle mich
wirklich besser ist war eine schöne zeit
mit dir annegret bis zum nächsten mal
ach ja und hier gibt's noch eine
playlist mit allen aktiva actions von
mir und hier oben noch ein für euch
persönlich vorgeschlagenes video bis zum
nächsten mal